Je rêve d'aller en bord de mer avec une fille
l'enlacer met la main dans ses cheveux et lui dire à quel point je l'aimais et  je suis là dans mon bureau à faire des vidéos
aaahh les fille,les filles quelle grande complexité comment faire passer le feelling comment se mettre en valeur
comment s'y prendre avec quelqu'un du sexe opposé ou du même sexe!
tout ça c'est l'école de la vie on apprend de nos erreurs on apprend nous-mêmes et on avance il n'y a pas de leçons à
suivre pas d'instructions pour réussir du moins c'est ce que je pensais ce jeu s'appelle super seducer c'est un mec qui nous donnent des cours
mais vraiment des cours pour nous apprendre à plaire aux filles alors souvent ce genre de truc c'est hyper misogyne l'hyper cliché est hyper
gênant bon super seducer c'est parti c'est des vidéos dans la vraie vie il y a des situations c'est un jeu à choix on va choisir
à chaque fois ce qu'il doit faire et nous dira ah bah non là tu as tort il fallait pas faire ça c'est parti "welcome to
super seducer thanks you so much for buy
and i hope you realy enjoy"
son petit sourire de fin étais fantastique le petit sourire du mec qui vient d'encaisser l'argent que j'ai mis pour avoir le jeu alors alors alors ça commence par
accoster une fille dans la rue
je sens que ça va être horrible d'un autre côté je vais apprendre à se dire des femmes et sans ce mec est ce jeu
je ni arriverai jamais donc story mode  ces partis allons-y
Il est si sur de lui c'est drole
oh déjà ça m'a surpris putain a b c d e f quoi y'a trop de choix et ce qu'on approche directement de devant est ce
qu'on approche un peu de côté et ce qu'on fait semblant d'être aveugle
moi je dirais qu'il faut faire semblant d'être aveugle quand même dans cette situation je veux dire en plus c'est très éthique
Ok alors on y va en face ah y'a la musique sais que c'est le bon choix regarde
Quand tu tombe sur la bonne explication d'un coup il y a deux meuf un poil à côté en tout cas c'est bien il considère pas du tout
la femme comme un objet le but ce n'est pas de finir dans un lit avec des femmes en sous vêtements non non non c'est
de créer vraiment une relation sympa
après j'ai mon esprit curieux qui a envie d'aller au bout de ce truc
alors maintenant qu'on l'a arrêté et qu'on a deux femmes à poil dans notre lit
qu'est ce qu'on lui dit je t'ai vu et je veux juste te dire que tu es très élégante euh t'a une minutes
c'est pas déjà vus à mes cours de yoga
se trouve très belle j'aimerais qu'on aille toi et moi maintenant est ce qu'on n'est pas allé au même collège tous les deux
Dit que tu veux vérifier ses boucles d'oreilles comme excuse pour avoir un contact avec elle trouve une excuse pour retirer ton t-shirt pour lui
montrer tes muscles
demandes lui quel coupes de cheveux t'irait bien ah bah oui mais ça qu'il faut faire gros
ça tombe bien ça ton tellement maire a bon maintenant que je sais séduire une fille dans la rue c'est bien mais moi j'ai souvent
soirée je veux savoir séduire des femmes en soirée aubin deux belles filles sont en train de boire du vin le but avoir un numéro
voir comment tu fais le premier pas on a paré de derrière le sofa
C'est pourquoi je lui dois la dessus moi bordel on leur demande de nous aider à choisir un cadeau pour un ami
Son regard elle est vénère elle veulent planter j'en peux plus ça me dérange trop là désolé les amis on sera pas séduire des filles
en soirée qu'elle d'aumale ah là là on est tous triste vraiment le niveau suivant qu'est ce que ces mecs
dies je priais pour que cela
C'est pour ça que jamais en soi quand on fait cette fille nous plaît putain mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait bordel to work attaque
Voir qu'est ce qu'on fait putain pas dormir seul ce soir bordel alors on fait un bon rôle
L'aqua mundo au cul les batailles comme tu danses la presse j'ai jamais fait de
moonwalk en soi et je demande et lui ce qu'elle aime faire à ses heures perdues
Yes
yes suis plus objectif j'ai juste envie qu'ils se fassent reculer tout le temps
bon tout ça c'est beau mais alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on lui demande si elle veut s'asseoir parce qu'elle doit être fatigué d'avoir dansé
depuis si longtemps
Est ce qu on lui met la main dans les cheveux et qu'on lui dit qu'elle a de petites oreilles mignonne et secours hier sa
bouche pendant qu'elle part on lui dit qu'elle nous plaît vraiment et qu'on aimerait l'embrasser où on lui attrape les fesses
bon à faire du complément sur les oreilles
Ok c'était les oreilles fallait on a réussi à danser un peu avec à la faire s'asseoir à parler on se connaît un peu mieux
on lui suggère de venir chez nous
j'avais jamais chez une inconnue comme ça alors je suis un mec mais je le ferai quand même pas puisque je suis un
mâle très peu alpha oui on lui demande si elle a déjà fait l'amour dans le vestiaire d'un club
vous avez vu mon corps réagit on lui demande si elle voit quelqu'un
C'est lourd bon alors la suite est-ce qu'il est temps de lui dire que on
connaît un endroit avec de la meilleure musique et du bon vin à cas chez nous ce qu'elle va percuter
Alors du résultat on a eu son numéro on n'a fait que
50% de choix correct ça on passe clairement pas assez de temps soirée à essayer de séduire des femmes alors n'est que ce niveau c'est
quoi de zinc à fond temps différent en vraie
Ville d'auch
y a rien derrière le rideau tu fais une sorte de vidéo tuto pour aux arts comment aborder une fille dans un café mais dans
le café ya que l
es tu toi c'était pas ça la vraie vie au
starbucks gros y'a pas que toi une fille à l'insuline chez aurel passé dans les premières phrases que tu peux dire à la fille a
encore le coût du doigt faire un cadeau à une amie
est ce que tu peux m'aider et gros il a réussi à sortir avec une femme dans sa vie la première fois qui lui a
parlé c'est grâce à cette phrase s'accroche depuis il s'en passe plus gros
Enfin je suis en train d'apprendre souvient des femmes vous pouvez pas faire ça les gars vous pouvez pas faire ça
bah c'est une blague mais
je suis au piège légal très loin il est temps qu'on l'attend on peut se poser mais on voulait vous de vous annoncer qu'on serait
pas fait que tu l'as vu tu lui as demandé des conseils pour offrir un cadeau à un ami
c'était comme ça que vous attendez
donc le jeu ça marche bien je trouve ça commence à être un poil on l'a prise demain
Là on commence à transpirer un poil et à mélanger nos sens oui et c'est agréable pour moi je sais que du plaisir
regardez bien il ya un petit point commun entre cette
Même j'émettrais
les cheveux aucun de nous trois mais parsemé au coeur de toile un début de calvitie
tu sais que par contre j'avais pas le terrain des buts de kalou voire pas du tout tourne toi et regarde simple c'est magique on
arrête plus tard jack championnat prend la subir des tables regardez ça c'est ce que j'ai pour les télés et tous et pour les vidéos
à tampa
Bay au poivre de cheveux
Vesta vraiment zéro je veux jeu là c'est pour ça que ça marche pas il en a il y en a beaucoup quand même pas
pour un
Problème pour les amis c'était la petite interlude calvitie fit au lit et
carlito bon nous en arrivons au tutoriel pour qu'une amie devienne votre petite amie
Mais il écrit pied que ses amis gros comme si je veux ça
comment faire le tuto commencé cet ami vous envoyer oh mon dieu les mecs sont vraiment des connards j'ai besoin de te parler tout de
suite qu est ce qu on fait comment allons nous faire pour que cette fille devient notre petit film c'est pour que cet ami devienne
autre petit ami qu on répond immédiatement avec un je suis là pour toi on attend un petit peu avant de répondre à ça on
connaît bien il faut toujours attendre pour faire un peu mal alfaro montrer qu'on n'est pas au pied de quiconque ne
L'exclus ce que j'ai à dire bonjour que c'est un peu plus intelligent qu'est ce que tu fais pourquoi tu réponds pas
répondre désolé j'étais occupé tout va bien pour répondre désolé j'étais occupé à faire ça et lui envoyer une photo d'eux
on lui répond bien évidemment désolé j'étais occupé tout va bien elle répond qu'elle a besoin de te parler et de te voir ce soir
oui
oui j'en
ai la tête voir
Courir jusqu'aux yeux frères attendez attendez
Ok cela il va chercher un truc on ramène de bouteilles de champagne on les ramène du vin on les ramène un arbre
meiway putain voilà c'est ça le secret pour patrice tapé de rupture il te
Faisait son truc c'était pas du tout un art moi je veux tu ramènes un vrai rebond thuram nhn gêne
C'est elle qui a rompu c'est pas lui à
c'est pour ça qu'elle est venue en mode sur son trente-et-un bien maquillée tous apparemment toujours quand tu fais une rupture tu te mets pas
comme ça tu es en combi de ski frère tu sais pas pourquoi tu as métriques de plus à l'aise et le plus chaud que
tu avais sous la main étaient là comme ça
c'est pas ses amis sont là pour toi au volet dit qu'elle a bien fait alors il se passe quoi
Alors la titille
à la chatouille je croyais en la beauté maintenant l'achat
De tout analyser ya juste eu des guilis là tu vas pas de faire une certes à sion sur les guides et putain
Gros à la fin il se passe quoi seuil en arrive au point on peut faire genre qu'on se bat et l'embrassé
m
Sa technique pour sortir de la fredzone s'étaient déguisés est ce que quelqu'un te vends cette vidéo est déjà sorti de la fredzone en faisant
des guilis non les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur cette vaste connerie qu'est ce jeu n'hésitez pas à aller mais ciel vous
a plu la vidéo pas le jeu putain vous mettez pas de pression pareil quand une fille vous plaît n'y a pas de méthodes mathématiques
appliquées et je dis ça je suis pas du tout un mec qui gérera point que les filières mais par contre je sais que je
ferai jamais ça court terme le mec qui fait des
mathématiques en tout cas je vous souhaite de rencontrer
l'amour en avoir du succès auprès des hommes ou des femmes ou des deux faites ce que vous voulez avec votre cul tout vous appartient
c'est vos organes génitaux c'est votre cerveau c'est votre corps mais par pitié
l'appliqué pas des méthodes plus au filet et si vous vous plantez c'est pas grave on apprend de ses erreurs on avance on s'en fout
allez je vous fais des bisous je retourne faire des effets concours de majorettes
Je vous dis à bientôt en tuant les zigotos lolita au foot j'ai commencé un café